I was really Zeldin as a Republican
represents the state of New York he says
he wants the memo supporting evidence
released right away congressman thanks
all for joining us tonight to be with
you tiger
so you say that the documents we were
just talking about for example the the
evidence the FBI brought to the FISA
Court to justify spying on this American
citizen quarter-page ought to be
released to the public what's the
argument against that the argument
against it would be that there could be
some information over the course of the
FISA application as you're viewing all
the documents that will include sources
and methods that may need to get
redacted in the effort to argue against
providing any of the related material
that was sourced some might say that we
shouldn't be releasing any of it the
counter-argument that I would provide
though to that is that anything at all
that can possibly be released to the
American public it's one thing when you
read the majority memo that was released
today it's another thing when you get an
opportunity to read the shift memo when
when that comes out but when you
actually are seeing the documents
created by the Obama Justice Department
and the Obama FBI and you're seeing the
FISA abuse and the misconduct at the
highest levels of these agencies for
yourself and the documents are actually
created by them then the American public
is able to form their own independent
judgment on their own without having to
rely on what might be filters of Adam
Schiff through a third party in the
media you know through a Twitter account
and then you're being educated on
believing that say the memo that got
released today was going to have all
these sources and methods that shouldn't
or when Schiff was complaining that it
was going to you know you get the point
I mean when he was talking about you
know those details I mean it's when
reality comes out and the memos you
could see for yourself
well so quickly the the thing that
Democrats are pushing back against
tonight is the really the pivotal line
in the memo that says Andrew McCabe and
behind closed doors testimony to the
Intel committee said the memo was the
basis in a fair that dossier was the
basis
the request for the before before the
FISA Court can we get a copy of that
part the relevant part of his testimony
absolutely and we should the transcript
should come out and people could see for
themselves and once again Adam shift in
the house and tell Democrats that
they're just lying as they said they
were complaining that Devon Nunez and
the majority were making changes to the
document right even though that some it
was just grammatical changes and and
those other substantive changes that are
made where changes requested by the
minority on the Intel committee as well
as the most substantive change which was
done by the FBI
exactly Congress thanks for coming on I
appreciate it